основная цель нашего курса академ
планирования и power management как
основа счастливой жизни заключается в
том чтобы вам дать окончательный полный
инструмент планирования и исполнения
своих задач и дел и достижения всех
ваших жизненных целей я это могу
утверждать основываясь на всем моем
многолетнем опыте в каждом планирование
сошлось все она покрывает все аспекты
вашей жизни это планирование всей вашей
жизни а не какого-то бизнеса либо
общественных дел прошло много лет но
планирования не бросил и более того я
даже его усовершенствовал я очень много
времени трачу на него
если вы досконально изучите и внедрить в
свою жизнь эту систему
то вы увидите что во все стороны вашей
жизни у вас как бы как как будто
откроется второе зрение и вы будете жить
успешной наполненной смыслом и
счастливой жизнью
сразу должен заметить курс достаточно
большой это не теоретический курс
а именно практический курс вы будете
выполнять огромное количество дел
просто огромное количество дел по
сравнению с тем что вы делали раньше
причем большинство ваших дел будут
именно
завершенными делами потому что цель
любой системы планирования заключается в
том чтобы увеличить количество
завершенных дел по мере завершения дел
или выполнение огромного количества дел
вы не будете терять сил энергии и
энтузиазма
выполнению задач станет для вас приятным
стимулирующим занятием у вас появится
азарт и вы навсегда забудете что такое
апатия депрессия упадок сил и
прокрастинация это вступительный урок
для того чтобы вы поняли о чем будет
речь
к чему готовиться и если вы готовы
изменить кардинально свою жизнь тогда
поехали